Topping our
world lead, police
flooded the streets
to crush
a remarkable uprising in major
Chinese cities
last night, fueled
by the country's strict COVID po
Rare dissent
over the ruling party and severe
Chinese government censorship.
On Monday, police in Shanghai
ordered citizens
to delete any photos
or videos of the protests
they even took subway passengers
phones, apparently
deleting social media
apps such as the popular WeChat,
which is already heavily
censored by Chinese authorities.
Let's go right to CNN's Alina
Wang in Beijing, China, for us C
In some cases, police
are even going further than that
Yeah, there are even reports
from protesters
that police have visited their h
I mean, China here,
they're using its
playbook of repression, surveill
individual intimidation tactics.
And also police flooding the pla
where protests have broken out
in recent days
and proactively going to any pla
where potential future
protests are planned
in order
to stop them from ever happening
I was at the protests in Beijing
this week
when I went back
to the exact same location
the following day.
It was eerily quiet
with masses of police cars
as far as the eye could see.
And what is chilling here, Jake,
is that some of this intimidatio
playing out in broad daylight in
metropolitan cities,
police randomly
stopping people
walking around
where protests broke out in Shan
You can see in the video
they're ordering people
to delete content from their pho
There are other videos
that appear to show
police randomly
checking the cell phones of pass
on the subways in Shanghai.
Protesters have told us that
police are checking
if people have installed VPNs
that can be used to
circumvent China's firewall.
Protesters
deep in order to use banned
apps like Twitter and messaging
apps like Telegram for communica
Now, remember, the key purpose o
giant security apparatus
is to prevent
social unrest like this,
to stop the momentum in its trac
And it appears to be working
because protests have become sma
more scattered since Sunday.
And social videos show police
breaking up
an attempted protest on Monday
night in Hong
Jo with video
showing a woman being
dragged away
screaming police violently
pushing people around Jake.
And Celina,
a Chinese party official,
finally issued an official,
albeit veiled,
response to these protests.
What did they have to say?
Yeah, exactly.
This was
the first reference,
but it was incredibly veiled pri
to this.
Officials had been completely ig
what was happening.
And, of course, censorship
on overdrive
to erase every evidence
that these protests ever happene
So state media on Tuesday
wrote that China
must, quote,
resolute Lee
strike hard
against infiltration
and sabotage activities by hosti
as well as criminal activities
that destabilize social order.
Now, this follows
what one protester told us.
This protester
was part of a large group of peo
that were detained on Saturday n
This person said police told the
they had been used
by ill intentioned people
who want to start a color revolu
This person also said
that the large group of detained
had their fingerprints,
retinal patterns, collected
other personal information
A reminder here, Jake,
that this is a police state,
that these protests had
occurred under a
shocking, extraordinary event